what happened last night was the Hillary
Clinton managed to stave off a lot of
momentum by Barack Obama comeback win
Texas and Ohio in ways that she wouldn't
have won a week ago voters who decided
the last minute broke for her voters who
were thinking about their
commander-in-chief broke for her voters
who are thinking about NAFTA broke for
her Hillary Clinton was able to stop
Barack Obama's Ament momentum because
she raised lots of questions she hadn't
been successful in raising before she
had a couple externalities helping her
out with this and I don't think I don't
predicted that saronite live would
become a pro Hillary infomercial but it
did I don't think anyone predicted that
libertarian I guess free market leading
economist Austan Goolsbee would kick
such an own-goal for Obama and you know
the details his competing with Canada
but NAFTA would be leaked but that
happened the one thing she controlled
was rephrasing the question of who could
be commander-in-chief in a powerful way
by portraying these little moppets being
tucked into bed a mother looking in on
them saying that think you had to think
about these and what the
commander-in-chief would be doing at
3:00 a.m. when you were thinking about
who you wanted to give the presidency to
and even though Obama had won the vote
of people who said they were looking for
a commander-in-chief in Wisconsin he
lost it here really handily and that was
the factor John McCain emerged is the
last man standing because the luck that
Hillary Clinton had in the last four
days he's basically been having for
three months he needed Rudy Giuliani to
run a terrible campaign that happened he
needed Fred Thompson to become basically
vegetative and that happened he needed
Mitt Romney to lose Iowa after spending
so much money there and be crippled New
Hampshire that happened he was able to
come back because the party sort of
tauros all apart and he is very lucky
right now because the Democrats are
going to be fighting at least till April
22nd while he who has never been a good
fundraiser or quote you know or a good
campaign manager to be honest given the
results of of 2001
happened to his campaign last year he
can get Bush's endorsement today he can
unite the party this week he can raise
the millions of dollars that Republicans
was supposed to raise and hire all the
smart people while the Democrats are
distracted what we need to look for in
Pennsylvania is if Obama can answer
these questions that he couldn't he just
completely lost the argument on about
NAFTA about commander-in-chief being
pander in chief in these white rural
areas of Pennsylvania that look a lot
like the white rural areas of Ohio he
unless there was some recounting it
looks like he's only won five counties
in Ohio if he does that in Pennsylvania
he'll if he wins
Philadelphia and Pittsburgh and not much
else he'll lose it in her speech last
night Hillary Clinton rolled off states
that she won and mentioned Michigan and
Florida that was important because
that's another card she's trying to play
these super delegates who do who now see
you know who know that Barack Obama has
won more than a hundred fifty more
delegates than she has if you don't
count those states she wants to ideally
get close enough by the end of the
primaries that if they just put Florida
which where they're neither candidate
was allowed to campaign because the DNC
basically prevented them from doing so
if they just give her the delegates she
would have won in Florida she clinches
it
if McCain runs as good a campaign as
George Bush ran which is not something
he's ever been proven to able to do but
he's got the Republican machine behind
him if he runs that good a campaign and
the Democrats were bloody John McCain
wins the presidency last night they're
liberals I talked to were more full of
resignation than they've been I think
any time since 2004 just because they
think what could have been easy primary
for if Hillary Clinton had wrapped up in
Iowa if Barack Obama had wrapped up last
night is going to continue grinding on
while John McCain looks more and more
like an adult